bonsoir elle est si poulain merci d'être
avec nous rétablir le service militaire
obligatoire ça pourrait être utile dans
ce contexte selon vous alors il s'agit
pas seulement du service militaire c'est
un service civique
l'idée c'est d'avoir des jeunes qui
seraient utiles à la communauté à la
fois au sein de la police des pompiers
mais aussi des associations pour de
lutte contre le changement climatique et
autres
donc c'est beaucoup plus parce que
simplement la conscription de l'époque
et le service militaire et c'est un peu
l'idée du s est nu si vous voulez qui a
été porté par la majorité actuelle mais
avec
un dédommagement à hauteur du smic donc
c'est assez différent puisque là les
jeunes seraient payés pour travailler à
des fins utiles pour la société alors
surtout selon la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon coni conscrits ont effectué
des missions au sein même de la police
il dit ça pourrait changer le regard de
la population c'est un début de piste
alors c'est une idée effectivement de
dire que si les enfants des uns et des
autres sont au sein de la police on aura
un regard différent un regard de
l'intérieur
il est temps effectivement de cesser de
faire de la police 7 ce camp adverse
pour certains avec ses appels au meurtre
de policiers acab all cops are bastards
etc
donc oui si les familles comprennent ce
qu'est la police voient leurs jeunes qui
disent on pendant un an neuf mois au
sein de la police pour des missions de
service civique
ça changerait sans doute le regard que
les français auraient de leur police
puisqu'il se l'approprient rey à nouveau
il comprendrait que cette police
elle fait corps avec la république et
qu'elle n'est pas là contre les citoyens
mais bien au service des citoyens et
c'est ce qu'elle est d'ailleurs la
police c'est juste que les images des
dernières années font qu'on commence à
douter que la façon dont est traitée
sont traités les manifestations aussi
font peur aux manifestants et donc il
est temps de changer ce regard il est
temps aussi de 2
de rabibocher les populations et
notamment les français avec leur police
et changer les pratiques de celle ci les
pratiques internes notamment comme le
dit le leader de la france a soumis ce
weel à la question bien entendu de la
doctrine de l'encadrement de la
formation
d'ailleurs il n'est pas le seul à le
dire gérald darmanin en parlait devant
une commission devant l'assemblée
pendant qu'il ya un problème de
formation de formation continue des
forces de l'ordre de la façon dont
aujourd'hui les les gendarmes les
policiers ceux qui sont là pour protéger
finalement ne sont pas formés
complètement ils sont formés à des
gestes techniques ils sont formés bien
sûr au niveau du droit mais il ya tout
un travail qui va au delà sur
l'encadrement sur l'humain sur la
désescalade qui a été fait d'ailleurs
part des voisins européens mais pas
forcément qui a été le choix de la
france et il est temps de se poser la
question de la doctrine et de
l'organisation interne de la police
et donc ce service national
au sein des forces de police permettrait
peut-être de voir aussi d'avoir regardé
extérieur et de faire évoluer le travail
des forces de l'ordre au sein des
quartiers et au sein des populations
merci alexis poulain pour votre
éclairage à merci à vous